insane walk Tech talks that will make
you cringe let's [ __ ] go nobody needs
you to advocate for how difficult it is
to use gender-neutral pronouns nobody
said that the gender binary was
these are not my preferred pronouns
these are my pronouns you will use them
or you will not refer to me
at all just don't refer if you misgender
me by mistake I'm good with that well
it's just we shall no longer refer to
you at all sounds good
fix it and move on I don't need your
elaborate apology no we're not I don't
care how many times you say hold on bye
bye pumpkin let's just move on what's
next [ __ ] her [ __ ] them just don't do
it again moreover if someone else
misgenders me it is never your job to
tell them that it's okay
I mean it she wants us to move on from
her let's move on from her all right
sounds good [ __ ] her the real problem
with her is that she's so high and
mighty about being right and she just in
if you can't even talk say my name right
don't talk to me pull yourself together
you [ __ ] child there are non-binary
people there are trans men who who
lactate there are those who go by he him
different pronouns it's just inclusive
to everybody it is not a women what
about my feelings who decide that they
want to be men they are the ones that
are lactating men are not lactating like
if they just would calm down on the
language I'm lactic and say trans
instead of saying trans men or trans
women lactate they say men because they
insist that it's just a regular man and
it's a whole full man it's not so stop
with the [ __ ] stupid language and
we'll stop treating you like your
[ __ ] retards being CIS women to say
chest feeding but it does hurt those who
go by other pronouns to continue to stay
breastfeeding especially if they have
body dysmorphia that you don't ever
everybody's got problems with their body
okay I have stretch marks I have a
c-section scar I've got no I know you're
worth it but my point being like no
there were so few people that are just
like my body is lovely and perfect even
supermodels supermodels you want to go
dig into what goes on behind the scenes
and their heads they're nuts they all
they do is criticize themselves so we're
gonna pretend that science isn't real
because somebody has a some trans person
man doesn't like the term breastfeeding
we gotta all change it to chest feeding
I say we just no stop watching the show
all right stop giving a maritime you
know what what part we're part of the
problem by giving a maritime honestly we
are we are because we're the ones maybe
it gets views but we're the ones making
videos out of this [ __ ] like before the
internet these people will just go and
do their own thing they wouldn't get the
light of day now magically with Tick
Tock because you know with Tick Tock you
get millions of views for free that's
how I teach now they have their own big
platform and it's a big [ __ ] deal
like why are we even talking about this
like everyone should just hear like oh
they them [ __ ] all right go call
yourself right who cares and now we're
the ones like watching and criticizing
it we're the dummies we're the dummies
too cute sexual people may decide to
have a sexual relationship despite not
feeling sexual attraction While others
don't both are completely valid and
communication is key what is that her
pronouns uh backup because I don't have
any idea what she just said because I
what is a cubiosexual that's a good
question Mom good good that you asked
the sexual orientation of people who do
not experience sexual attraction but
it's a still desire to be in a sexual
relationship so that means you fool
around with people you're not into I
feel like the dummy for watching this do
you prefer pronouns uh zazam oh I've
never heard those before what are they
uh they're what's known as Neo pronouns
what are Neo pronouns they're basically
your own custom pronouns when no other
pronouns seem to fit you come up with
your own pronouns anything can really be
a pronoun oh how do I use them
um it depends on the person and their
pronouns zazam follows a similar
spelling to they in them
and even similar grammar rules like
zarin's air so Zay ZEM ZEM Sal there's
things like that oh okay and there are
other new pronouns you said well yeah
because they're customizable anytime
I'm watching the video are you learning
and studying did you take notes trying
to pay attention I'm sorry what's your
point how do they function remember the
one we saw who was in the bathroom
crying
uh staff Awards they misgendered her or
used the wrong pronouns or something and
she was crying I got misgendered and I
presented my award and we're watching
this video of this grown ass woman
crying because of the smallest thing
[ __ ] business studies [ __ ]
business study my teacher for business
studies looks like a [ __ ] games she
couldn't get through a day without a
complete bug out now how did these how
did if these people are real and there
are this many of them like it's sad that
this is how a lot is bad but it's sad
that a lot of the teachers and stuff are
so politically correct that this is the
[ __ ] that they're literally teaching
kids because the school system is so
left nowadays it's [ __ ] I remember
when I worked at a restaurant and my old
teachers would come in and I would hear
them talk about like their college life
I'm just like these people are dumb
asses like I can't believe I used to
listen to your word like iron as a child
three times three yes I used to I used
to used to like not look up to your
teachers but like that's an authority
figure but you were told that this was
somebody that was new with their [ __ ]
and you were gonna learn from them and
go in there and pay attention [ __ ]
business study you're broke oh when you
get to know their personal lives yeah
that's crazy for real you go to college
to learn from a professor that drives a
[ __ ] car and doesn't make money I get it
sometimes they were successful in
business semi-successful they made like
a few hundred grand and then they go and
they they want to get a teaching degree
they want they want to go and start
teaching like that's sometimes but why
if if there's someone that's truly a
successful business person wouldn't you
want to go and learn from the actual
business person and work with them and
be like I'll work with you for free I'll
run your social media campaign I'll do
anything just to be able to work with
you be able to get closer to the money
or do you want to go learn from the dude
his money's locked up in a retirement
fund till he's 65 because he did it the
right way [ __ ] it's [ __ ] you
don't need time to get rich nowadays you
don't time anything that's over a few
years is a dream if you have a plan to
get rich and it's going to take you
longer than realistically I'd say I'd
honestly say two years max if you can't
figure out how to make a ton of money
from this business plan in two years you
gotta move on or at least get really
stable and and be equivalent in so many
ways to make money nowadays it's
everywhere but if the alternative is to
watch Tic Tac all day and complain about
your pronouns I'm just gonna do that hi
I'm Jax and I just came up with new
neopronons that combine he him she her
and they them okay
so hear me out
they them theirs okay they them there
whatever you want to consider it right
it's like the first one D okay this
combines it's a biology
and they right yeah right right before
the mustache the beautiful skin the
pretty eyes the the the mild chin okay
that's what they said you know that's
what they said next we got bin right
okay so then we got that's just
combining them and him them
yeah I went to a movie with him the
other night
last one there's okay it's just like
theirs
but like also like hers
thirst that jacket's thirst yes this
just sounds like they them pronouns but
with the new Ultra scientist if we don't
if the whole world doesn't adopt it then
you're offended I mean seriously and
we're we're the reasons everybody's got
to be worried about you everybody's got
to be worried about this human being
about them them or are they there's
everybody's got to be worried about
theirs feelings and experience what's
the direct correlation to something that
happens when they're growing up that
leads someone to be like this obviously
we haven't done any studies and we don't
know but I'll say this maybe they're
just a little weird and I guess they're
standard instead of just rolling with it
you know what I guess 50 of people are
weirder than the average person yeah but
you just roll with it just be weird why
you gotta [ __ ] hit the gas and be
ultra crazy weird just to fit into some
I don't know you just decided that
they're weird like what do you learn
like but like what's the matter with
just being regular weird
um I'm trying to phrase this nicely and
I can't yell but I want to so
um black people
and people of color in the queer
Community aren't seen by white queers as
as Queer as they are on almost every
occasion where I've been discussing my
queerness or my experiences with
queerness with white gays they speak to
me in a condescending way and they treat
me as if I am a straight person imposing
on a queer subject because they don't
see us as as Queer as them queanus is
seen as something that is white and a
way to to compare a practice
do you know what's going on in someone
else's head unless they very
specifically said hey black [ __ ] you
don't know what queer means to be there
like if they said that then you know
that it's about your color but they're
just a little consent they just make us
maybe they just think you're a [ __ ]
idiot and they don't they don't that has
nothing to do with your color of your
skin everything isn't about race these
people just complain they can't think of
enough things this is what happens when
you listen to the government non-stop
you get all your shots you do everything
you listen to them yes I'm oppressed yes
white people they're the devil yes I
know every time a white person looks at
I'm either looking at me with hatred
that's what happens when you constantly
adopt that kind of thinking it's just
it's a sad way to view reality because
she's so brainwashed by the people at
the top of the Matrix that you can't
even see that you're just a little Pawn
in this whole game and they're just
trying to keep you distracted with
[ __ ] you look at your phone all day
you scroll on Tick Tock for constant
dopamine you don't allow yourself to
have any original thoughts and then here
you are making up pronouns and issues
and you're broke you're broke I really
you're so right you're so right but but
look let's look 10 years into the future
and what's gonna happen mom like no
really we're gonna look at these all
these videos that we're watching I will
bet my soul that these people are not
saying the same [ __ ] in 10 years
22. thank God there wasn't social media
because all the things I believed like
ah I'll tell you right now what's gonna
happen they're gonna live in a [ __ ]
Hut and they're gonna eat bugs to save
the climate people genuinely believe
that cow we need to get rid of cows
because they fart and it's ruined in the
environment people genuine genuinely
believe that cow farts are ruining the
environment you need to go vegan if you
can't see the agenda behind that I don't
know what the you know you slap in the
face you got to wake up you need to wake
up too though because okay I'm gonna
tell you what Grandpa always told me and
my sisters let's hear it you know this
one Hey kid you know what you know
nothing you don't know [ __ ] okay you
don't know [ __ ] and my grandma my father
used to say that to me and when I was
about 25 I woke up and I realized that
yeah you know what I don't know [ __ ] all
of a sudden everything that I thought
was I was so sure about from you know 16
17 18. I knew everything I didn't know
anything and I still don't know [ __ ] and
so I'm constantly questioning and trying
to learn so even you being so confident
in your in your speaking you don't know
[ __ ] kid 10 years no 10 years from now
right think about 10 years ago I'm gonna
eat bug I should just start eating bugs
and you know you're right maybe the cow
farts really are ruining the environment
I can't wait to watch this in 10 years
you're actually right she's going to
change as a human being she's going to
grow up and have experiences and get a
little perspective some of them are
going to stay freaks because you know
freaks are freaks hey you know buy your
flag but she's gonna grow up and she's
gonna look back on this and go oh God
gross I can't believe I said that and I
said it in public I'm worried about 10
years from now how they're gonna feel
after they've cut off their body parts
and they've filled themselves with
hormones and they've decided that they
oh my god what have I done well my brain
wasn't even fully formed and it made all
these sick choices that we're gonna have
a real interesting conversation mark
your calendars everybody right now for
November
2032.00
[Music]
oh my God you guys have your masks on
breathe out
[Music]
trans men and women too
it's breathing
breathe out Breathe In Breathe Out Mr
Producer sir
[Music]
okay you've never seen black people
being like let's get the kids and go to
a drag show no like and yet and yet they
managed to suck them into this [ __ ]
am I so what's up with like the black
pride lgbtq flag being everywhere that's
what I'm saying like why are they
sucking them in because
my son's a girl now no no no no if
anything it's like it's like the last
group of people to go and be super
accepting the men are you go to the
emergency
like I you know I'm sorry like it that's
what it is it's an LGBT black lives
matter flag why the [ __ ] is that
everywhere who the [ __ ] whose idea was
this it's the white people doing this
[ __ ] it's because it's all there's the
lgbtq umbrella and then there's the BLM
umbrella and then there's the big
umbrella both things under it I would
bet what's left in my solo that a black
person didn't come up with that [ __ ] I'm
surprised black people don't get like
kind of upset the black community like
from from my white Sicilian Irish
perspective American perspective like
they they have pride in their [ __ ] and
their culture they're not just looking
to jump onto his legs other flags
they don't fly a freak flag they fly a
black pride flag they're not flying a
freak flag like why they're doing all
that and smashing it all in together is
just be like hey let's I'll be victims
together and we they think that by
combining victimhood that they're
they're getting stronger I know and all
they're doing is making us all go you're
just getting crazier and less effective
no yeah you're right it's crazy what the
[ __ ] man what the [ __ ] all right guys
thank you so much for watching I just
launched my full get [ __ ] done Academy
where you can learn all of my Tick Tock
marketing skills e-commerce how to make
money online call outs basically
everything you need and it's only 30 a
month so if you want to stay broke don't
join don't really give a [ __ ] but if you
like what we have to say and you
recognize that we're actually
semi-intelligent people know what we're
talking about then you can come and
learn so I'll smile you later he's very
intelligent I'm always semi-intelligent
but I'm having a good time
all right thank you guys
[Music]
[Music]